in March of 2019 12 year old Johnny
Smith was hit and killed while walking
home from school his mothers created a
toy drive in his honored to give back to
the children of Sunrise Hospital and as
our Madison Kimbrough reports each year
on Johnny's birthday the donations just
get bigger and bigger
is it possible for me to donate some
items to Children's Hospital to Sunrise
Children's with the money I would have
spent for a birthday gift for Johnny so
that's all I was thinking and that
thought turned into an annual tradition
of gift giving to the children of
Sunrise Hospital Susan Smith
spearheading the idea the first three
years it was 2500 to 3 000 worth of
items this year is over five thousand
Smith who lost her son Johnny in 2019
when he was hit by a car while walking
home from school wanted to honor him by
creating a toy drive and donating toys
in his name this toy drive always taking
place on February 5th which is Johnny's
birthday and each toy is special in the
fact that the kids get to keep them with
the hopes of taking them home once they
get healthy enough to leave the hospital
local Road Safety Advocate Aaron Breen
explains it's not like a little toy
cupboard that kids get to go pick games
and then put them away because they're
ill
they stay with them Smith's sharing that
while life without Johnny will never be
the same she continues to keep his
Spirit Alive by surrounding herself with
those who knew him best all of his a lot
of his friends were are my mom friends
so we still see each other we still some
of them they donated some of the stuff I
can see them grow and and get older and
I kind of get an idea of you know how
tall Johnny would be and what he would
be interested in they're all links to
Johnny
to me they're all like a little piece of
his life
that was outside of his life at home
so they all have stories to tell and
yeah
or Madison Kimbrough with that story now
the toys donated range from Barbie dolls
Electronics Arts craft sets this year
Johnny Smith would have been 16 years
old